In life, being focused helps us ignore distractions,...
...but this focus can cause us to overlook unexpected opportunities.
Similarly, when we focus our attention on finding a particular object,...
...we often fail to notice other unexpected objects,...
...a phenomenon referred to as inattentional blindness.
Dr. Trafton Drew and research colleagues...
...from the Visual Attention Lab at Harvard Medical School...
...decided to examine if inattentional blindness...
...also exists in the eyes of trained experts such as radiologists.
In a recent study published in Psychological Science,...
...Dr. Drew asked 24 radiologists...
...to search for signs of lung cancer in 239 frames of a chest CT scan.
In this stack of images, he inserted five consecutive frames...
...containing an image of a gorilla.
Despite superior ability of radiologists to detect lung cancer nodules,...
...20 of the 24 radiologists did not report noticing the gorilla.
Interestingly, eye tracking revealed that most of the radiologists...
...who missed noticing the gorilla had looked directly at it.
Looking right at something might not be enough to notice that it's there...
...if you're looking for something else.
This study suggests that even experts who routinely detect cancer nodules,...
...which are about 48 times smaller than the image of the gorilla,...
...are also susceptible to limitations of attention.
By understanding these limitations,...
...future research may help reduce errors committed by experts...
...in diagnostic radiology, baggage screening,...
...and many other professions that involve searching for items...
...that are difficult to find.